[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
nathalie d'interdire cela fait un peu
plus de trente ans depuis 1986
exactement que le bo privatisation après
une place de plus important de plus en
plus importante dans le débat public
on peut même dire qu'il a remplacé le
mot nationalisation qui avait tué son
heure de gloire entre 1945 et 1980 mais
depuis la crise du coc vide le retour de
l'état interventionniste
le retour de l'état providence est salué
comme une revanche et comme une
résurrection
enfin pas pour tout le monde il ya aussi
ceux qui voient dans l'état tisme le
véritable mal français alors faut-il
tout privatiser ou plus rien pour en
débattre nous avons invité laurent
mauduit qui est journaliste co fondateur
de mediapart bonjour laurent mauduit et
vous publié aujourd'hui à la découverte
de prédation une histoire des
privatisations des biens publics
privatisation qui serait le résultat du
néo libéralisme mais aussi de
l'affairisme et provoquerait depuis plus
de 30 ans la destruction l'état social
et la marchandisation généralisée
pourquoi c'est le bon moment d'après
vous de lancer ce débat leur nuit c'est
le bon moment tout le temps tant les lie
à deux menaces qui pèsent sur les biens
publics
je vous en donne juste une illustration
vous avez vu sans doute que le 15 ou le
15 ou comme par hasard au creux des
vacances qu'un décret a été près par le
gouvernement paru au journal officiel
qui étend à certains tronçons de routes
nationales la privatisation des
autoroutes voies la menace constante et
donc vigilance constante alors jean
philippe feldman vous êtes professeur
agrégé de droit vous êtes avocat à la
cour de paris et vous enseignez à
sciences po et vous publié chez odile
jacob exception française l'histoire
d'une société bloquée de l'ancien régime
emmanuel macron avec une préface de
mathieu laine pour vous au contraire la
france n'a jamais été libérale néo
libérale encore moi c'est l'étatisme qui
règne depuis des siècles les français
préfèrent l'autorité à la liberté ils
sont égalitariste et envieux dites vous
champion des prélèvements obligatoires
et de l'interventionnisme d'état rétifs
au libre échange et à l'amour
réalisation et c'est ça qui en fait
d'après vous une société bloquée
pourquoi c'est le bon moment de lancer
ce débat de poser ces questions-là jean
philippe feldman
bonsoir de mon côté je serais d'accord
avec mon contradicteur
je crois que c'est un débat intemporel
donc je ne suis pas sûr que la période
actuelle soit une période adapté qu'il
ya quelques mois ou quelques années
alors y en a on a tout de même vu
fleurir et c'est laurent mauduit qui le
remarque dans son livre un slogan qu'on
a vu fleurir au moment de l'arrêt fait
là la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites mais qu'on a repris aussi au
moment dé des grèves dans les hôpitaux
publics c'est quand tout sera privé où
sera privé tout ce slogan on va le
retrouver ici les il est juste derrière
moi derniers mois derrière moi j'ai du
mal à parler aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que votre vous à votre
avis l'euro mode lui c'est un certain
vous avez dit c'est un
une prise de conscience ce slogan ouais
c'est une prise de conscience parce
qu'en fait on a vécu deux grandes étapes
dans les privatisations
il ya d'abord eu les privatisations des
grands groupes industriels et financiers
des banques
c'est essentiellement de 1986 et tout au
long des années 90 est donc apte à cette
époque là le débat est assez circonscrit
au milieu politique il ya des débats
publics sur le prix des privatisations
vous souvenez est-ce qu'on brade ou pas
les bijoux de famille mais voilà c'est
pas un débat qui est très populaire
et puis à partir du début des années
2000 les privatisations change de nature
comme on a quasiment tout privatiser
dans la sphère commerciale
on commence à privatiser ce que
j'appelle par commodité d'expression les
biens publics a donc ce sont les
autoroutes de 1000 cc sont les aéroports
ce sont les services publics et donc
dans ce progressivement le sujet devient
un sujet très populaire et notamment ça
le deviendra beaucoup pendant la crise
de l'hôpital parce que d'un seul coup on
se rend compte que cette marchandisation
touche aussi la santé publique touche
aussi la sécurité sociale et donc d'un
seul coup et puis ça touche souvenez
vous du débat politique autour
d'aéroports de paris
ça devient un sujet populaire c'est pour
ça que le slogan est très révélateur
d'une sorte d'appropriation collective
par les citoyens d'une question qui est
importante parce que c'est bien ce sont
les leurs jean philippe feldman et ce
qui lèverait ce slogan c'est un slogan
absurde
ils ont des choses pour clairement place
laurent a cité la vérité mais quand des
sociétés communistes auraient été
certainement des idées alors c'était
exactement le contraire moi je dois dire
on fait alors qu' il ya une confusion
entre le gouvernement et la société
ça n'est pas parce que l'état ne fait
pas quelque chose que pour une fois
c'est le secteur marchand qui va
intervenir
l'alternative ça n'est pas simplement
pour vous bien
simplement que ce sont les individus ils
sont chargés d'un certain nombre de
choses donc pas forcément l'état mais ça
peut être aussi la sphère non marchand
par exemple les associations
à condition bien entendu qu'elle ne
reçoit pas de subventions c'est vrai
laurent mauduit que à ce slogan on
pourrait dire c'est quand tout a été
nationalisée qu'on a été privé tout
cette attaque faisait allusion jean
philippe feldman
enfin moi le la conviction que j'ai
c'est que au terme de ce mouvement de
déçus et glace qu'on a vécu sur très
longue période parce que les
nationalisations commence dès 1908 ya
une première très grandes
nationalisations
on a connu des vagues alternative de
nationalisation et de privatisations et
j'ai le sentiment qu'au bout de plus
d'un siècle de ce mouvement il ya de la
part des citoyens une frustration c'est
que le sentiment dominant c'est que la
propriété publique souvent c'est aussi
mal comporté que la propriété privée
je rejoindrai peut-être mon
contradicteur sur ce point l'état
actionnaire gérer le capitalisme d'état
dans un univers qui est très
financiarisé se comporte aussi mal
prenons juste un exemple à titre
d'illustration renault dont
l'actionnaire principal reste encore
l'état avait 15 % c'est dans cet univers
totalement financiarisé ce groupe hors
très mal avec un patron par exemple
l'ancien carlos ghosn qui avait 15
millions d'euros de rémunération avec
celles de nissan
et puis des inégalités en bas de
l'échelle sociale penser que chez
renault
un ouvrier sur deux est à l'intérim donc
c'est l'endroit où on était le plus loin
dans le système à l'anglo-saxonne des
working poors des travailleurs ponts
avec des inégalités formidable et donc
je pense qu'on a vécu très longtemps sur
une fausse alternative d'un côté l'état
de l'autre le marché
1 la gauche notamment a vécu sur cette
idée et je trouve qu'au point où nous en
sommes il faut tirer un bilan des deux
les privatisations c'est un saccage au
prive les citoyens de bien qui sont les
leurs est on en train de saper l'état
social et puis mes par ailleurs le les
nationalisations pour la plupart été un
fiasco on pourra donner beau
d'autres exemples pitoyable triste
l'histoire de pechiney qui se termine
par une op 1
voilà et donc je pense que le débat
maintenant le débat pour l'avenir
c'est à sortir de cette fausse
alternative
les privatisations ça a été à sa cage
pour vous jean philippe feldman ça
pourrait être à sa cage parce que l'état
est un mauvais gestionnaire ou un
mauvais actionnaires et donc ils vont y
vend mal ça pourrait être à sa cage
aussi parce que ceux qui l'ont racheté
font moins bien que ne faisait l'état
alors à votre avis je partage le point
de vue de mon contrat dit je ne dis pas
que les privatisations vous répéter un
grand succès parce qu'effectivement
elles ont pu être malmenés et qu'elles
ont pu être menées dans des intérêts
privés taux d intérêts qui auraient dû
être les intérêts des individus en
général bon ouvrage notamment je mets en
cause commune sur mauduit d'ailleurs une
épisode assez triste des privatisations
sous jacques chirac e numéro 2 entre
1986 et 1988
c'est à dire ce qu'on avait appelé les
noyaux durs selon l'expression
d'ailleurs assez bête il faut dire donc
dépénalisation n'avaient pas été menées
comme elle aurait dû l'être
si les systèmes de liberté avait pu être
respecté donc je ne suis pas favorable
aux privatisations en général à partir
du moment où vous êtes ressembler il ya
privatisation et privatisations dans les
pays du monde entier via des
privatisations qui sont fausses
privatisation il ya des privatisations
qui sont faites en faveur de personnes
qui sont privilégiés par les
gouvernements en place
mais c'est vrai que dans un ouvrage de
monsieur mon dieu on voit relativement
peu ce genre de chose si ce n'est à la
fin où il parle à genève petit de ce
qu'on appelle le capitalisme de
connivence ça ce n'est pas du
libéralisme le libéralisme c'est la
liberté si vous me berthe et des
individus ce n'est pas le fait d'aller
privatiser
et les services publics ou des
entreprises pour favoriser des intérêts
privés
laurent mauduit ouais non parce que il
faut rentrer dans le détail du sujet
pour voir à quel point les
privatisations même quand il n'ya pas de
noyau dur même quand il n'y a pas de
système de connivence entre les
dirigeants politiques et les dix agents
des affaires spolie les intérêts des
citoyens parlons clair prenons un
exemple celui des autoroutes
vous avez vu qu'il ya un rapport du
sénat qui est paru il ya quelques jours
qui donne une expertise avec d un
chiffrage plus large que celui que je
donne dans mon livre et le chiffrage est
très impressionnant il est celui ci si
le versement des dividendes aux
actionnaires les nouveaux actionnaires
des groupes d'autoroute privatiser se
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin des
concessions c'est à dire 2035 ou 2036 au
rythme où ils ont eu lieu depuis le
début des privatisations c'est-à-dire de
2006 à aujourd'hui
vous savez combien de dividendes les
actionnaires c'est à dire ceux de
eiffage de vinci quelques autres vont se
partager 70 milliards d'euros vous
rendez compte
donc c'est pas il n'y a pas une question
de pureté de gestion des privatisations
on spolie il ya eu j'aime pas les termes
populiste donc j'utilise des mots avec
précaution on a malgré tout fait un
racket des automobilistes des citoyens
pour organiser un immense transfert de
revenus au profit de quelques
actionnaires et donc cjs est au coeur de
l'idéologie ou de la croyance
néolibérale pardon de le rappeler le la
première grande vague de privatisations
au monde il faut le rappeler vous
souvenez fadec thaddeus a lieu c'est au
chili avec o'shea sous le chili de
pinochet et que commencent les
privatisations et donc il ya une
croyance est derrière cette croyance il
ya en fait une ce pollen spoliation des
citoyens alors je fus jean jean philippe
feldman peut-être à mossoul philippe
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
argument qu'on dit il
souvent ce serait l'école de chicago qui
aurait réformer le chili sous la
dictature de pinochet et au fond donné
le coup d'envoi de la vague de ce qu'on
appellera ensuite le néolibéralisme qui
atteint le royaume uni avec margaret
thatcher et les états unis avec ronald
reagan
je ne suis pas un défenseur
une chimie de pinochet je suis un
libéral c'est pour bientôt je suis
attaché à la liberté non je crois qu'il
faut pas tout mais les jeux ne suis pas
amateur d'un dictateur chilien pas plus
d'ailleurs que je n'étais un admirateur
et sociaux égoïsme chilien qui l'avait
prédit ce prêt cdétno chef faut pas
l'oublier non plus je voudrais qu'on
soit précis parce que monsieur m'ennuie
utilise souvent le terme de néo libérale
je n'ai rien à voir avec le
néolibéralisme
les libéraux n'ont rien à voir avec le
il faut être extrêmement précis en
utilisation des perles
le libéralisme n'a rien à voir pour la
simple et bonne raison que le
néolibéralisme c'est en fait un
mouvement d'intervention de l'état qui a
été inventé dans l'entre-deux-guerres
ça n'a strictement aucun rapport avec ce
mouvement tard il ya toujours ce
problème sur les termes libéral ultra
libérale néo libérale de toute façon le
mot libéral en france était très très
mal vécu sur le plan économique c'est
très mal vu d'être libéral en france
laurent mauduit et et ça peut faire rire
il faut bien reconnaître quand on
qualifie le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron ou de ses prédécesseurs veilleurs
de libéral ou d'ultra libéral ou de néo
libéral sachant que l'intervention de
l'état est permanente
oui attendait c'est compliqué parce que
il ya la sphère économique
il ya la politique économique et il ya
par ailleurs la gestion par l'état
en france le modèle du capitalisme
français est assez singulier parce qu'il
a connu des bouffées de libéralisme ou
d'ultra libéralisme mais dans une
culture politique qui est une culture
comment la dir
ils libéral au sens où l'entend par
exemple
l'historien pierre rosanvallon 0 nous
sommes dans une monarchie républicaine
avec une tradition de pouvoir et qui
fait que c'est une plutôt une démocratie
autoritaire et ceci est vrai sur très
longue période il ya du second temple
aujourd'hui on a eu une culture
politique assez proche et la singularité
c est ce que c'est de ces deux façons de
mener la vie d'un pays est ce qu elles
sont contradictoires
or la singularité c'est pour ça que je
faisais ce que l'inde a eu avec le chili
c'est que le néolibéralisme qui est la
vague dominante l'idéologie dominante
depuis le début des années 80 fait bon
mais comme la thérapie néolibérale et
très violentes se sont pas seulement les
privatisations
c'est aussi la dérégulation sociale le
plus souvent il faut des régimes forts
ou des régimes autoritaires et regarder
macron il est libéral ou néo libéral en
économie
regardez ce qu'il a fait en termes de
dérégulation du travail regarder ce
qu'il fait en termes de privatisations
même les routes nationales et en même
temps il se sert de tous les instruments
des institutions très antidémocratique
de la vème république
le vol bloquer l'assemblée les
ordonnances 1 voilà et donc c'est ça la
singularité du néolibéralisme pardon je
sais de jouer des deux thérapies
économique et sociale violente et pour
mener à bien ses réformes
l'autorité un peu c'est la théorie du
choc
vous le voyez comme un libéral emmanuel
macron jean philippe feldman un
ultralibéral 1
néo libérale ou à libéral contrarier
peut-être parce que parce qu'en france
le poids de l'état et quand même ce
qu'il est vous savez nos hommes
politiques sont avant tout des hommes
pragmatique
ce ne sont pas des idéologues il n'y a
que les mauriciens pour l'être
je ne partage pas du tout le constat
qu'ont mené d'une dérégulation sociale
on m'a par avocat en droit du travail
vous l'assuré n'est pas vu qu'elle était
la dérégulation en matière de brevets il
reste extrêmement imposante
je ne vois pas en quoi il ya eu des
changements si on avait voulu mener par
exemple dans ce domaine là il répond
véritablement un libéral on en serait
revenu à la liberté contractuelle est la
liberté du contrat de travail
donc on en est très très loin il
faudrait modifier le bien des choses à
commencer aussi par le fonctionnement
des syndicats français de maths il y
aurait beaucoup à dire
on parle de d'emmanuel matheron coma
libéral à oliveira et on nous dit il y a
eu des pirates isation desquels il n'y a
pas une seconde privatisation selon
manuel mata actuellement on n'est pas
sous le gouvernement ou même je saurai
vous par exemple je vous laisse est dans
un groupe au bord politique
oui c'était les leurs mais ben rien je
vous laisse est né ou du sucre et des
gâtines mention public
je vais visiter des privatisations
menées à bien par emmanuel macron il ya
eu les privatisations des aéroports
toulouse nice lyon il a piloté
là le décret qui sort sur les tronçons
de routes nationales et il ya par
ailleurs toute une série de
privatisation rampante qui a qui avance
celle par exemple de la sncf
avec l'ouverture à la concurrence qui
est évidemment une avancée vers la
privatisation progressive de la sncf
il en va de même avec la poste la poste
qui a été mis dans un mécano je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que c'est
compliqué mais avec la caisse des dépôts
et la caisse nationale de prévoyance et
donc du même coup la poste perd son
statut d'entreprise publique et est en
fait elle devient la filiale de sa
propre filiale la banque postale qui n'a
pas un statut de de service public et
donc il ya énormément d'endroits où les
privatisations notamment les
privatisations rampante moléculaire et
je pourrais aussi parlé très longuement
de la privatisation de la santé sous
emmanuel macron jeu saad
alors c'est vrai que c'est faut prendre
le temps de le décrypter mais le
mouvement de colère qui est autour de
l'hôpital public alors c'est tous les
gouvernements de gauche et de droite
enfin socialiste et de droite ont donné
des coups de boutoir multi blank si on
parle de l'hôpital public il faut
remonter à 2004
la tarification à l'acte et c'est chacun
a apporté sa pierre et mes dents dans ce
mouvement là emmanuel macron à apporter
les siennes et elles ont été nombreuses
alors répond jean philippe feldman
n'avait pas l'air d'accord mais pas du
tout évidemment là encore il faut être
extrêmement précis on ne peut pas tout
mais né et malheureusement monsieur
mauduit a tendance à souvent des
cotisations alors qu'il ne s'agit pas de
privatisation
on nous parle donc de la sncf n'avait
pas accepté une autre courte et baptisé
aujourd'hui on nous parle de la pause ne
savons pas que ça avait été privatisé
une privatisation c'est le fait de
passer d'une ces plantes uniques ou
secteur privé or il ya beaucoup de
situations intermédiaires
monsieur modules
et passe sous le coup de isation
en revanche là où je partage son contenu
s'est effectivement il y à ce qu'il
appelle des privatisation rampante dans
le sens où il y à une hypocrisie de la
part d'un certain nombre de nos hommes
politiques
au fil des années qui aboutissent
graduellement ou peuvent aboutir
graduellement vous de dizaines d'années
à des privatisations
vous avez un mouvement effectivement qui
n'est pas un mouvement est honnête
cela dit en l'état actuel des choses on
n'a pas eu de grandes privatisations
sous emmanuel mac os ou encore une fois
on n'a pas eu de mouvements tels pour ne
plus en avoir sous jacques chirac
alors justement à propos de l'hôpital
public vous à vous en avez parlé laurent
mauduit depuis le le confinement
les plans sociaux se multiplient mais
aussi les les faillis de l'état de
l'entreprise b des entreprises dont je
vous dis n'importe quoi les failles et
des entreprises et tout ça à chaque fois
on demande à l'état de venir à la
rescousse
est ce que est ce que vous pensez jean
philippe feldman qu'il faut que l'état
intervienne aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y
à un consensus sur l'idée selon laquelle
lorsqu'il y à une épizootie une épidémie
ou pandémie comme actuellement
l'exploit du rôle de l'état d'intervenir
les libéraux étaient sur cette ligne dès
le 18e ou 19e siècle mais il ya
intervention et interventions
intervention de l'état il faut pas dire
intervenir en permanence ça ne veut pas
dire supplée complètement le secteur
privé comme on a pu le voir ces derniers
mois où on a accusé une intervention
d'état extrêmement forte
tout de même lorsque j'entends monsieur
mauduit on vous dit un peu tout est
privatisé qu'il y à des privatisations
dans tous les domaines moi ce que je
constate c'est qu'on a
l'état providence nous développer au
monde le plus développé au monde
ça n'a pas changé lors de la course et
même aggravée lorsque j'écoute monsieur
mauduit on a véritablement l'impression
qu'on est dans un pays libéral
actuellement qu'il n'y a plus
d'entreprises publiques et que par
exemple pour repeindre les dépenses
étaient notamment les hôpitaux
parmi les pays qui dépense non plus donc
lorsque l'on parle de secteur public qui
se ferait à l'abandon et bien il y a en
argent considère qu'il est effectivement
en grande partie en pure perte
roduit
oui face à utah les il ya une ambiguïté
que votre question peut générer est-ce
qu'on assiste véritablement à un retour
de l'état
mais regardez bien là il faut rentrer
dans le détail du plan de relance qui a
été arrêté par le gouvernement
certes le gouvernement est à la
manoeuvre on le voit il annonce il ya
des effets d'annoncé autour des 100
milliards
voilà mais quand vous rentrez dans le
détail vous vous rendez compte que ce
gouvernement a bien sûr bouge il est
obligé mais il garde ses convictions
néolibérale pardon
ne pas embêter mon contradicteur
néolibérale regardez par exemple
l'aspect c'est toujours la politique de
l'offre aider les entreprises et donc
dans le plan il ya notamment cette
baisse de 20 milliards d'euros sans
contrepartie les qu'on appelle les
impôts de production et c'est assez
saisissant tout de même pas ce qu'on a
vécu sous le quinquennat d'avant pendant
lequel les manuels n'a qu on était déjà
mise de l'économie les mêmes politiques
ça a été le cic e puis le pack de
responsabilité dont plus de 40 milliards
d'euros offerts sans contrepartie avec
un bilan catastrophique on l'a
maintenant ça a été chiffré combien cent
mille emplois créés ou sauvegardés pour
une somme absolument fabuleuse donc en
fait on a arrosé le sable et ça n'a eu
aucun effet sur un emploi et on
recommence on aide la preuve est rien
par ailleurs pour le social
rien pour les travailleurs pauvres alors
toutes les associations qui s'occupent
de ce secteur tire le ciel là signal
d'alarmé
rien pour l'hôpital public alors qu'on
on sort de cette crise en sort on est
toujours dedans
1 je vous rapelle que au cours des cinq
dernières années on a supprimé 10 7500
lits hospitaliers
vous avez entendu un plan pour sauver
l'hôpital public donc regardez bien le
retour de l'état il est beaucoup moins
évident que ce que vous suggérez au
travers de votre question jean-philippe
fait le même c'est vrai que on a fait
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle les cadeaux
aux entreprises à la fois sous la
présidence de françois hollande est
depuis la présidence de d'emmanuel
macron et c'était le cas aussi sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
si ça ne marchait à l'ordre le but à
chaque fois est affiché c'est
d'augmenter les investissements c'est
toujours ce qu'on espère que les
entreprises investiront plus et que
elles emploieront davantage de gens si
ça n'a pas l'air de marcher c'est parce
qu'on s'y prend mal
ou parce que les l'initiative privée
malheureusement n'obéit qu'à une seule
règle celle du profit et la règle du
profit ne nécessite pas forcément
d'employer des gens
bravo est ce que je voudrais revenir sur
la question du retour de l'état parce
que dans votre présentation des missions
vous y avez fait référence c'est mon
contradicteur vient d'y faire référence
je crois que nous sommes sur la même
ligne à savoir le fait qu'il n'y a pas
de retour de l'état mais pour des
raisons totalement différentes mon
contradicteur le regrette
moi je nous considère qu'il n'y a pas de
retour de l'état je serais heureux qu'il
y ait un retour de l'état
pourquoi parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'il aurait disparu pour l'état n'a
jamais disparu
c'est un état qui est puissant c'est un
état qui est interventionniste ces
détails plus interventionniste au monde
voilà je réponds à votre fils nathan
d'interros parce qu'on doit faire une
pause juste là et je vous redonne la
parole juste après on n'a pas un
installeur et quand je faisais allusion
retour de l'état c'était plus dans les
souhaits on souhaite le retour de l'état
depuis la crise du coc vide qu'il n'ya
effectivement un retour de l'état ont
fait une pause et on y revient
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise sont des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous savez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les plis dans
des entreprises pour savoir lesquels
souffrait simplement du confinement ou
du ralentissement de l'activité il est
qu'elle était déjà en état de deux morts
avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production
laissons les impôts sur les entreprises
qui marchent et donc qui font du
résultat celles qui sont déjà son billet
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts vous n'allez
pas leur donner de l'argent en fait
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dire écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu voilà c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ce charmant en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec laurent mauduit
qui vient de publier prédation et jean
philippe feldman qui publie exception
française jean philippe feldman vous
aviez la parole je vous avais posé les
questions tous ces cadeaux aux
entreprises qu'ont fait les
gouvernements successifs sinon ça n'a
pas réduit le nombre de chômeurs comme
comme on l'espérait ce que c'est parce
qu'on s'y est mal pris
ou parce que les les entreprises
n'obéissent qu'à la loi du profit
alors je crois qu'une entreprise par
définition à la loi du profit sinon ce
n'est pas une encore pink wakili à des
théories aujourd'hui un peu différente
qu'ils soient développés
m un code je crois que là encore il ya
une confusion des notions de
néolibéralisme outre nous ne sommes pas
en velin libéralisme lorsqu'on est
libéral on n'accorde pas des veaux
entreprises et dans mon ouvrage
d'ailleurs je mets en cause mais
dizaines de milliards d'euros qui sont
déversées chaque année aux entreprises
bon lorsque vous êtes un homme de l'état
et que vous donnez de l'argent à
quelqu'un vous espérer quelque chose en
retour
et lorsque vous recevez de l'argent de
l'état va vous n'est pas forcément prêt
à lui donner quelque chose en retour
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
libéraux sont opposés au principe aux
aides de l'état aux entreprises et
j'attends peut-être de manière un peu
naïve
j'attends qu'un jour un homme politique
dit je ne vous donne plus d'argent je
vous donne plus de subventions je ne
vous donne une neige mais en
contrepartie vous libère je réduis vos
impôts etc
leur mode hui vous faites vous faites
partie monsieur fellmann d'une de nos
catégories re en voie d'extinction
rarissime ça me fait penser que longuet
ministre de l'industrie et en 86 qui
disait mon espoir
ce sera de supprimer un jour
ministère de l'industrie bon c'est quand
même une espèce rare
la singularité français c'est que les
aides aux entreprises d'une part soit
elle crée des effets d'aubaine
ça a été le cas sous mac rompt avec ce
que j'évoquais lé cic eux ce sera le cas
aujourd'hui avec le plan de relance ou
ça se greffent aussi avec on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure des pratiques
d'affairisme invraisemblable vous savez
que l'un des leviers publics pour aider
à l'investissement des entreprises bon
surmonter le choc c'est la banque
publique d'investissement la bpi est
l'apport de l'argent elle est supposée
les apporter notamment aux entreprises
moyennes pour les aider à investir et
préparer l'avenir
vous savez la dernière annonce là
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du plan de
relance de la bpi
ils ont décidé de mobiliser je voulais
cite à titre d'illustration 50 millions
d'euros pour qui
monsieur xavier niel qui est bien connue
être un petit entrepreneur qui manque
d'argent pour investir voilà c'est une
blague mais fascine d'annoncer une vraie
information mais qui dit bien le mode de
ce capitalisme 1,16 que dans lequel nous
sommes où les gens sont à la fois
néolibéraux et sur un fonds de 2 voilà
deux systèmes à ses traits consanguins
système et incestueux incestueux entre
la vie des affaires et la vie politique
jean philippe feldman suspect risque
notre point d'accord avec monsieur bell
ban il ya de ces de l'affairisme ce live
on est en pleine affairisme monsieur
moon lui même à trélon de dinosaures il
n'a pas pu vraiment peur parce
qu'effectivement il y des opposants face
et qu'on france je crois qu'il ya une
erreur parce que ça n'était pas monsieur
longuet de mémoire qui était ministre de
l'industrie en 1986 mais mon ami alain
matelas c'est alain madelin qui avait
dit qu'effectivement j'espère que je
serai le dernier ministre de l'industrie
que vous pouvez le transporter ça n'a
pas été le cas
est-ce qu'il faut bien qu'on n'est pas
dans un système de l'eau libéral mais
cela dit
jean philippe feldman c'est vrai que les
gens comme vous sont très rares en
france c'est pour ça que quand on dit
les libéraux les libéraux quand on
entend on se dit oh là là vous êtes le
seul à tenir ce discours
c'est bien la preuve qu'il n'ya pas tant
de libéraux que cela en france en
revanche votre discours dans les pays
anglo saxons est beaucoup plus répandu
aux états unis notamment
pas seulement dans les pays anglo saxons
les 7 10 ans que il est un peu plus
tenus dans d'autres pays mais c'est
difficile de le tenir - en france voilà
en france on n'est pas du tout comme ça
mais on l'est dans les pays anglo saxons
le néolibéralisme le capitalisme le
libre échange et la mondialisation
d'ailleurs sont beaucoup de tenue pour
responsable de la crise du coc vide et
de et de l'est et des conséquences
qu'ont pu avoir la pandémie j'imagine
que ça vous agace beaucoup jean philippe
bas non parce que finalement on sait que
la chine est un très grand pays libera
donc que je sache le virus est issu de
la chine qui est quand même le recordman
mondial du nombre de morts au 20e siècle
mon trêve de plaisanterie on a un virus
qui est apparue d'abord un virus est
quelque chose de naturel
le virus il n'est pas issu du
capitalisme non pas plus que du marxisme
au demeurant néanmoins c'est un virus
qui est apparu dans un pays qui ne verra
donc ça serait bien quand même qu'on
arrête de dire n'importe quoi en disant
qu'à mondialisation a favorisé ce genre
de chose par sur quoi on va revenir sur
l'histoire des grands fléaux d'épidémie
au fil des siècles mais on veut peut la
déplacer repos et pour vous leur produit
il ya quand même à réaliser je trouve
qu'il ya deux réponses différentes à
apporter à la question que vous soulevez
la première c est ce que
la mondialisation l'accélération des
échanges la favoriser là honnêtement je
ne pense pas que la question soit assez
documenté pour pouvoir l'assurer je
relève d'une pratique du journalisme
assez méticuleux et je n'aime pas dire
ce que je ne peux pas prouver en
revanche est une certitude c'est que le
néolibéralisme a fait a conduit à ce que
la france baissent la garde et soit
désarmé 1
rappelez vous on vit tous nous sommes
dans un capitalisme celui le capitalisme
rhénan le capitalisme des trente
glorieuses où il n'ya pas dopé à dans
l'europe continentale il n'ya pas de
paix a et c'est vrai jusqu'à la fin des
années 90 aussi bien en france qu'en
allemagne bond et d'un seul coup
l'accélération de la mondialisation
le basculement est de la france et de
l'allemagne d'un capitalisme dire et non
vers un capitalisme anglo-saxon fera en
se fera aura pour conséquence le fait
que d'un seul coup les op avons arrivée
et danser au pea bas ce sera qu'une
série de bijoux industriels dont la
france dispose et qui vont europe être
croquée alors j'ai cité tout à l'heure
pechiney mais regardez ce qui s'est
passé dans l'industrie de la santé de la
même façon et donc dans cette vaste
réorganisation mondiale avec production
dans les pays à bas coût de main
d'oeuvre et centres de recherche dans
les pays développés c'est vrai que la
france a perdu la maîtrise en matière
industrielle sur les médicaments c'est
en chine pour l'essentiel est donc dans
cette nouvelle division internationale
du travail
il est certain que liés à cette
mondialisation la france est devenue un
pays mal protégés est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas a ajouté jean philippe
feldman que au fond les
et c'est ce sont parmi les champions des
prisons utilisation et du libre échange
les pays anglo saxons les états unis
d'abord et le royaume-uni ensuite qu'on
a au fond les pays
parmi ceux qui ont le moins bien résisté
aux que vides ce qui compte le plus de
morts par million d'habitants
je ne suis pas sûr que la france soit
très bien placé pas tellement ce n'est
un peu mieux et pour ce qui concerne et
pour ce qui concerne la baisse du
produit intérieur brut
je crois qu'on est très très bien placée
en la matière dans trois qu'on a
relativement peu de leçons à donner
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que soul
l'a5 public
lorient mais où il ya des équipes
japonaises simples auxquelles a passé
conséquence de la mondialisation entre
guillemets on tape dans mondialisation
actuelle
eh bien on n'en parlait pas mais il ya
eu des dizaines d'idées en france à
répétition du fait qu'ils ont circulé
dans la générale aujourd'hui pendant
cette app est pas mort vous avez à une
journaliste qui apparaît est
effectivement à un problème qui est en
tête de l'actualité
j'ajoute que la mondialisation actuelle
est peut-être un vecteur de transmission
des virus parce que si les frontières
étaient plus fermes et peut-être que
vous virus irène moi ce n'est même pas
évident mais bon pourquoi pas au nom de
cette hypothèse mais ce qui est sûr en
tout cas et on peut le constater c'est
que la mondialisation actuelle permet
aussi la résolution des crises et on
voit effectivement toute l'ingéniosité
notamment des entreprises ces mêmes
durant la crise et même en or ou les
entre eux il met par l'état leur nuit
oui je suis enfin je trouve qu'il ya des
secteurs de la vie sociale où l'on voit
très bien les ravages auquel conduit à
la fois la mondialisation et la
marchandisation généralisée qui découle
de cette forme de capitalisme
financiarisé
prenez un exemple et à mon avis beaucoup
de français le long vécu l'ont vécue de
manière très très dramatique qui est la
dépendance on aurait on serait resté
dans la logique ancien de la sécurité
sociale la dépendance aurait été le
cinquième pilier de la sécurité sociale
là comme l'état a été défaillant et a
laissé le marché avancé dans une logique
libérale du coup quelles sont les grands
acteurs de la dépendance le plus grand
je vous le dis c'est c'est le groupe
korian
c'est le géant européen des maisons de
retraite médicalisées
vous savez combien gagnent la pdg de
korian c'est bien un indicateur de la
privatisation rampante du secteur de la
santé elle gagne à un million d'euros
elle gagne plus que certains des pdg du
cac 40 et kate elle voulu faire pendant
la crise du coc vide elle s'apprêtait à
verser en dividendes à ses actionnaires
de korian 58 millions d'euros de
dividendes voilà donc c'est un secteur
où le capitalisme à l'anglo saxonne a
envahit alors que dans une logique
d'état providence
on aurait dû à linverse trouver des
systèmes pour rester dans un système
solidaire là pour les vieux on est sorti
du système solidaire
les vieux riches peuvent s'offrir une
maison de retraite médicalisée les vieux
pauvres relève de la débrouille et de
l'entraidé familiale
on est dans un système où le
néolibéralisme fait des dégâts sociaux
absolument dramatiques sont philippe
fuellemann il aurait fallu refaire pour
les personnes âgées ce qu'on a fait pour
la sécurité sociale aux fonds mutualisé
de deux observations
d'après les dépenses parce que là on
dépensera un champion congrue cinq faux
produit intérieur brut
pour ce qui concerne la france
correspondent aux dépenses de santé
encore une fois vous mets au sommet
européen avec niveau de l'allemagne
il y a deux cent mille fonctionnaires
aura fonction publique hospitalière
je crois qu'il faut pouvoir dire qu'on
dépense a énormément
en effectif qui concerne la dépendance
il faut pas se plaindre et des décennies
on a des milliers en france en
l'expression de mon ami mathieu laine un
état nounou qui s'est substituée aux
familles
et aujourd'hui on dit à bientôt d'un
coup les des femmes il n'exerce plus
leur fonction
l'état doit se substituer à elle est
finalement l'état remplit mal c'est
uniquement faire les choses autrement ne
pas détruire la famille comme cela avait
été le cas
il essaie peut-être un petit peu plus
d'argent aux individus pour qu'ils en
fassent ce qu'ils souhaitent plutôt que
de ne le reprendre ensuite déversé un
puits sans fond qui ça promet sécurité
sociale française
l'euro mauduit enfin oui oui non mais
bon je recevais une cadette de moquer de
vous je trouve que vous êtes monsieur un
peu doctrinaire vous vous affichez vos
croyances
moi je vous parle de choses très
concrètes pour les personnes âgées
est-ce qu'on reste dans un système
solidaire où est-ce qu'on passe dans un
système individuel qui relève de
l'assurance privée et donc moi ma
conviction et je peux le documenter
c'est que progressivement de plus en
plus les logiques de c'est la logique de
la privatisation on rentre dans un
système d'accumulation personnel là
c'est vrai pour la dépendance c'est vrai
tout autant pour la retraite la dernière
formule que l'on connaissait de la
réforme des retraites que quesnel nacre
on voulait faire passer qui est toujours
d'actualité puisque le bis des finances
a annoncé qu'il n'y avait pas renoncer
c'était vous souvenez la possibilité
pour les gros salaires au-dessus
schématiquement 10000 euros par mois de
pouvoir sortir d'un système solidaire
pour pouvoir passer dans un système
proche de la capitalisation
donc en fait le système qu'on nous
annonçait était un système de retraite à
points universel universel sauf pour les
riches
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je parle de
marchandisation et la privatisation
c'est que dans tous les systèmes
solidaires on sent là
jean qui s'insinue et la logique du
profit qui avance laurent mauduit
en ce qui me concerne l'état me prend 50
% de ce que je gagne en impôts sur le
revenu et aux prélèvements obligatoires
et ensuite il perçoit un certain
pourcentage de ce que je dépense grâce à
la tva
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'argent
cet argent je n'ai pas le choix je veux
dire par là que je n'ai pas le choix
c'est comme ça il est logique que
j'attende de la part de l'état au moins
une certaine efficacité parce que sinon
moi qui fus pour la solidarité je suis
totalement pour la solidarité
mais si c'est ce que l'on me prends ça
n'est pas efficace je vais finir moi
aussi par me rebeller me dire ce serait
mieux si on privatise et où est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que l'état a en
france a une grande responsabilité dans
le fait que de plus en plus de gens
alors on va les accusé de séparatisme je
ne sais quoi d'autre je parle sur le
plan économique
au fond se fâche de plus en plus avec la
solidarité parce qu'ils aient leur
semble que ça n'est pas efficace ouais
de deux il ya des pays aux états unis
par exemple où on vous aurait pris
beaucoup plus ça au début des années 80
avec un impôt sur le revenu qui
attaquent parfois 90 % du revenu donc
non c'est toi sur la chaussée sur la
dernière tranche ensemble bien sûr mais
cela dit la singularité du système
français
c'est que ce que l'on vous prend en
grande partie on vous le rend 1 et donc
mais et donc du coup la conclusion que
j'en tire c'est pas du tout le rôle de
l'état on est dans un système de salaire
différé
vous prendre soin de votre salaire et ça
revient sous forme de prestations la
vraie question la suivante c'est qu'en
fait il ya eu progressivement une sorte
d tat isation l'état s'est mêlée à
l'origine de ce la sécurité sociale
notamment 1 et donc du coup la vraie
question c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'en
france les nationalisations ont toujours
pris une forme particulière qui est l
étatisation c'est pour ça que je parle
aussi de prédation c'est quoi on a
enlevé les citoyens prenez la sécurité
sociale si c'est un salaire différé
pourquoi sommes nous sortis d'un système
de démocratie sociale ou c'étaient ceux
qui paient les salaires employeurs et
employés qui gérait cet argent et en
fait on se rend compte que partout
l'état a mis son nez à casser toute
forme de démocratie sociale et à priver
les citoyens du contrôle de leur propre
bien alors c'est très caricatural dans
la sécurité sociale mais pouvait temps
le raisonnement sur beaucoup d'autres
secteurs
jean philippe feldman oui
écoutez j'ai un contradicteur qui a
beaucoup d'humour j'étais un gp un
dinosaure tout à l'heure je suis un
doctrinaire maintenant vous devez pas le
taquiner mais bon disant je ne suis pas
un jeu se disent de temps sans
méchanceté mieux
non mais je vous taquine aussi un petit
peu le principe mais est ce qu'une mère
c'est le skite assez rarement karl marx
ou pierre bourdieu avec faveur alors
j'étais beaucoup aimé ce qu'a dit mon
contradicteur lorsqu'il dit ce qu'on
vous prend en roulant alors et vous
taquine r6 tissage et de bourre en ce
qu'on vous a pris c'était pas la peine
de vous prendre à ce moment là moi j'ai
fortement la presse et la boutique
solidaire à dix regroupements
oui c'est la solidarité français mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que quand
en vous prendre pour ans et on vous rend
entre les deux il ya une personne qui
vous a pris quelque chose qui s'appelle
des tapas et quand l'état prend il faut
que l'état fonctionne pour l'état est
extrêmement lourd en france lorsque
l'état vous a pris en fait il vous rend
peut par définition derrière et ça c'est
un gros problème
depuis bien longtemps à ces problèmes de
l'interventionnisme français un problème
que vous voulez résoudre à votre manière
laurent mauduit
vous dites que au fond vous n'êtes pas
pour l'état gestionnaire vous êtes pour
pour un retour au commun les communs
effectivement peuvent se passer de
l'état
oui vous savez il ya eu des époques dans
l'histoire notamment au début de ce
qu'on appelle le mouvement ouvrier au
début du 19ème des formes de solidarité
qui s'éloignait de l'état ou les déforme
de d'appropriation collective des formes
de solidarité des sociétés d'entr'aide
et donc si vous vous promenez dans les
premiers socialistes
proudhon fourier même jusqu'à marx
pardon de le citer une fois vous avez
ses formes et les premiers socialistes
n'étaient pas des partisans de l'état
il ne disait pas que l'ambition
principale c'était de prendre le pouvoir
de l'état c'était de créer des sociétés
et ça a été le cheminement regarder ce
que ce que font ce que fait la commune
de paris elle crée des coopératives
ouvrières
donc il ya le débat à l'épaule comme ne
paraissait pas l'état c'est comment
c'est un débat sur la propriété et je
trouve que c'est un débat qui est
formidable et que assez peu souvent on a
l'intelligence d'ouvrir ce débat manière
sereine est ce qu'il n'ya pas des formes
est ce qu'il ne faut pas aller au delà
de la propriété est ce qu'il n'ya pas
des inventions démocratique à le faire
pardon je veux donner juste un exemple
je suis journaliste à mediapart et à
mediapart on a décidé de loger le
capital de mediapart dans une structure
non lucrative à une époque où tous les
grands médias sont rachetés par des
milliardaires à 1 donc on nous sommes le
premier journal français sans
actionnaires est-ce qu'il ya pas dans
d'autres secteurs d un manchon du même
type à faire pour renouveler les formes
de gestion collective des biens publics
je dis ça parce que je pense que la
presse devrait être un bien public
et quant à vous jean philippe feldman
l'idéal ce serait quoi alors écoutez
d'abord les vidéos ne sont pas opposés
aux sociétés d'entr'aide et autres ont
pu exister au 19e siècle
je ferais remarquer que ce type de
sociétés a disparu du mois à cause
justement de l'interventionnisme de
l'état y notamment les sociétés de
secours mutuel ont été littéralement tué
par l'interventionnisme sous le second
empire
alors que c'était des sociétés et des
associations en réalité qui se développe
est remarquablement bien avant outre
manche mais on l'état a voulu intervenir
parce qu'il avait peur que ces
associations de des ouvriers se
transforme en
alors j'avoue que sur cette question des
communs je suis un petit peu perplexe
parce que je trouve que c'est
extrêmement floues il ya une confusion
entre comme un bien commun public ça est
très à la mode actuellement la gestion
collective des biens publics j'ai du mal
à comprendre ce que ça à ce que ça veut
dire
en revanche effectivement il peut y
avoir autre chose que de la
marchandisation entre guillemets autre
chose du secteur privé je dirais
financier commercial qui s'intéressent à
l'argent qui se développer à partir du
moment où l'état n'intervient pas et
qu'il s'agit de libre aux initiatives
privées n'y a eu strictement aucune
difficulté ça me paraît même une très
bonne chose mais en revanche il faut
effectivement la liberté est pas
l'argent public derrière et et à votre
avis jean philippe feldman les l'état
ayant fait la preuve à vos yeux de son
inefficacité de sa lourdeur il faudrait
qu'il se retire de quoi où et on le ne
lui laisserait que quoi alors je crois
que le débat était mal posée y compris
par certains libéraux certaines
personnes se disant qu'ils libéral tel
délire entre mm
on a appris à faire qui m'apparaît
absolument central du mauvais côté c'est
à dire on s'est demandé s'il s'agissait
de supprimer et là il ya eu 10 c'est à
dire le fait que certains ce n'est
qu'une proposition qui était fait et
c'était à qui mieux mieux c'est à dire
c'est qu'il allait supprimer 500 mille
postes de fonctionnaires d'autres ce
qu'il s'est passé lors de la primaire de
la droite
je crois que c'est une très mauvaise
façon d'opérer le problème c'est
effectivement de savoir si une mission
doit être exercée ou non par l'état soit
la mission doit être exercée par l'état
et ce dernier doit recevoir des moyens
adaptés
soit l'état doit contrôler les choses et
laisser faire le secteur privé on doit
agir en conséquence tout retour l'état
ne doit pas interdit est donc
effectivement là à ce moment là il doit
y avoir il validation c'est de cette
arme on pourra résoudre la question de
la lourdeur dans mauduit oui la question
des communs c'est une bouteille à la mer
c'est que chacun doit pouvoir se
l'approprier parce que à l'échelon de
petites entités on voit bien quelle
forme ça peut prendre ici une forêt l'un
barrages hydrauliques pour empêcher une
privatisation là pour empêcher la
privatisation d'un tronçon de route
nationale on voit bien comment il
pourrait y avoir un contrôle
démocratique collectif d'un bien public
dans un espace limité la complexité
c'est quand le bien public est de taille
importante par exemple les services
publics les services publics qui vive
précisément dans un cadre national c'est
le principe même du service public c'est
la péréquation des tarifs et donc
l'égalité d'accès de tous les citoyens
et donc moi j'avance quelques idées dans
le livre surgelés 10e la sécurité
sociale sur la presse mais je pense que
c'est en grande partie un des bacs
collectifs c'est le moment pratique qui
réglera le mode de goût
annonce de sorte que les citoyens aient
leur mot à dire alors on voit bien
comment le débat avance
vous avez vu que par exemple piketty
dans son dernier livre avance l'idée
d'augmenter la participation notamment
des représentants des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises
une sorte de son modèle c'est la
cogestion à l'allemande ça me semble
très très faible comme idée parce que la
dérégulation sociale a été aussi forte
sinon beaucoup plus en allemagne qu'en
france et donc je pense que voilà c'est
un débat collectif à mener pour donner
des formes multiples à cette gouvernance
collective démocratique à inventer je
vous remercie tous les deux jean
philippe feldman normes d'hui devoir
participer à cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à